hello there it's been a while since this
series was around and now the christmas
period is over we can get back to
spotting secrets on the new island as
well as recapping the story of the
season so far if you'd like this series
to continue please drop a like and
here's my code too so chapter 3 began on
december the 4th making today the start
of week 6 only 23 days until your
lobbies are filled with the rock we're
going to look at how chapter 1 and
chapter 3 are linked and io's invasion
attempt but of course we will start with
the weather update
[Music]
storm season is officially here in
fortnite for the next seven days the
tornadoes will be common in your battle
royale game then after that they'll cool
down a little bit from our early tests
two on average form in each match with
the most common one a thunderstorm which
darkens the sky and strikes thunderbolts
and lightning at spots on the ground
which are highlighted with this blue
warning sign if you're hit though don't
worry you lose a little health but you
get a short speed boost too so it could
be used tactically if you want to get
hit every time to maximize that
potential simply sit in bodies of water
near the strike zone or scale a mountain
and get as high as you can because
thunder likes to hit the first point it
can reach which tends to be the highest
areas and in our tests it worked 100 of
the time we got hit a lot in all this
frantic tornado action you may have
missed the missions given to us by the
scientists let's quickly recap that
when we made it over to the new island
many of us noticed the seven rocket
silos for the seven suddenly one of
those opened over christmas and on
christmas eve a huge map update was seen
a rocket appeared at the first silo this
wasn't any rocket though this is the
exact same model as the one spotted
jumping through realities in season x
it's also arguably the same rocket we
saw locating the zero point all the way
back when live events were first being
made so this leads to two questions
is there more than one single rocket and
wasn't the original rocket in chapter
one simply a prop which was converted
into a functioning rocket by the visitor
sadly the rocket in chapter 3 went on a
space voyage without us it was off
camera one day it was there the next it
was gone and we were told it was in
space so here is my high-tech recreation
of the rocket taking off
you're very impressed aren't you i can
tell this actually gives us a little
more law now we know the island acts
like a planet it has a gravitational
pull it's just a flat version in space
we can now take an educated guess that
the rocket from chapter one almost
certainly looped around space and came
back down at the opposite side of the
island the visitor's mission that day
when he crash landed was to find the
zero point and escape unnoticed that's
why he's here in chapter three just
hanging out with the boys back to the
scientists according to him the first
rocket we sent this season into space
had failed it was on a reconnaissance
mission maybe looking for another member
of the seven the paradigm so our first
rocket recon mission failed
but you know what they say when one
launch pad door closes another one opens
and behind that door there's a bigger
rocket with more telescope parts in it
which you will go and source for me
right now
this is very exciting for you after
collecting those telescope and
surveillance parts the scientist goes
back to the drawing board and will soon
unveil a new rocket version two so
here's a question do you think it will
be the exact same design as the last one
maybe just bigger like the one he made
in season x hopefully he'll soon find
paradigm so we can get this story going
i also want paradigm back in the shop
because i didn't buy that skin and i
regret it to this day if you're on
paradigm i expect you to be flexing in
the comments
[Music]
so while we were all getting free gifts
over christmas in our cabin did you look
around this place it's filled with
little buttons giving us small surprises
like a remote control car zooming by if
you clicked on the safe in the back of
the room you may have seen a host of
easter eggs from llamas to gingerbread
men and if you're one of the cool kids
you will literally see easter eggs at
christmas how matter is that then
suddenly the scientists gave us another
mission in week three unforeseen
rumblings could be felt underfoot the
scientist was unsure if this was due to
the island's rotation or something else
it was then revealed it was definitely
something else over by the logjam
building a drilling vehicle rose to the
ground the imagined order had dug
through from the other side all the way
to the new top site in exactly one month
they made it through this coincided with
sloane's update in appearance to
surviving colder climates she got a
snowsuit and the first drill arrived in
the snow with io back on the island
things are going to get spicy between
the 7 and io but wait this was only one
part of the plan during week 5 another
io drill appeared much lower on the map
in the south a second unit already with
more to come we are told fn assist tells
us that there are five drills in total
coming to the island with a designated
letter omega and ryder are here and then
there's dash epsilon and raven to follow
shortly now take a look at the first
letter of each of these omega rider dash
epsilon and raven they spell out order
how cool is that i know it's a useless
easter egg but it's still pretty awesome
the imagined order has everything in
place because order is everything right
now the snow is going away and soon the
island will lose its white topping and
we shall soon see what the island really
does look like which means tilted towers
will be here in one week it's thawing
right now as we look at it in game if
you sound like me you've been watching
it for weeks looking forward to the day
half the lobby is eliminated in the
first 60 seconds of every single game
you will ever play for the rest of the
season yay so that's our update this
week thanks for sticking around to the
end here's some legends from my discord
who use my code and i'll be back in my
twitter dms tonight to thank all 55 of
you who've used my code this week thank
you kindly i'm adam you're awesome i'll
see you next time
[Music]